In a call with my doctor this morning she introduced the idea of metronomic chemotherapy,
that is 10% of the normal strength.
I searched your site and didn't see a topic mentioned.
I would assume this would have considerably reduced side effects.
We have been successful at keeping the prostate toer from spreading for about five years now,
but we don't seem to be making significant progress at knocking it down.
I have avoided the toxic and invasive treatments thus far.
Do you see metronomic chemotherapy as a logical baby step in that direction?
So yeah, you're just trying to think through your option.
So number one, metronomic or if you're using insulin to stimulate the uptake of it,
it's called insulin-potentiated chemotherapy.
So you're giving a shot of insulin, waiting for a period of time,
and then doing 10% the dosage of chemotherapy.
Well that idea first surfaced about 25 years ago.
It was very exciting because if we could get the cancer cells to uptake the chemotherapy,
much more efficiently, could we not give a lower dose of chemotherapy?
Well, it had been proven to be successful, but the problem is it's not always successful
like anything else. First of all, if chemotherapy isn't going to, if full dose chemotherapy isn't
going to work for a person, then then low dose chemotherapy isn't going to work for the person.
And the truth is, is that full dose chemotherapy only works for a percentage of people.
So if the full dose is not going to work for you, then the low doses are going to work for you.
So chemotherapy is a drug that's increasing oxidative stress.
What's problem is it doesn't work for everybody. So it's then that's the struggle. Now with prostate
cancer, I'm surprised they're offering that to you because prostate cancer historically doesn't have
a great success rate with chemotherapy. It's not typically what is even recommended unless
they have run out of other options. Typically with prostate cancer, they will recommend
androgen deprivation therapy, which basically shuts down all your testosterone. They'll
recommend possibly surgery, possibly radiation, and then they'll get down to chemotherapy. So
it wouldn't be the first choice simply because there's a lower success rate with chemotherapy,
with prostate cancer versus like breast cancer. But if I thought the chemotherapy was going to work
really well for me, would it be wise to start with the lower dose chemotherapy? Yes, it makes sense.
It makes a lot of sense, but there's negatives to that too. So if you're going to do the lower dose
chemotherapy, typically you have to do it much more frequently and you have to do many more sessions.
So while you may not get the abrupt illness jumping right into full dose chemotherapy,
you can still lose your hair, you can still get really sick, you can still, it just will take
over a greater length of time. So there's pros and cons to it, so look into both those things.
And again, if it's not, if chemotherapy isn't going to work for your cancer, low dose chemotherapy
is not going to work either. You don't have any greater success rate of that.